en novembre dernier la commission
européenne demande 28 états membres
la mise en place de l'étiquetage des
produits issus des colonies israéliennes
des colonies illégales au regard du
droit international
une décision qualifiée de technique par
l'union européenne face aux critiques du
gouvernement israélien qui la
considèrent éminemment politique
un à quatre pour cent des produits
israéliens seraient concernés
colère du premier ministre israélien
benyamin nétanyahou l'étiquetage des
produits de l'état juif par l'union
européenne réveille de sombres souvenirs
l'europe devrait avoir honte même si
l'europe sont défend tsipi hotoveli vice
ministre des affaires étrangères ajoute
la dictée disons les choses clairement
c'est purement et simplement boycotter
israël les palestiniens se sont
félicités de cette décision mais l'ont
jugée encore insuffisante
en réponse l'état hébreu a annoncé la
suspension des discussions avec l'union
européenne sur le processus de paix
israélo-palestinien un processus de paix
au point mort